OK, let's hear from a few more folks.
Via discord, you can join the discord at
David Pakman dot com slash discord. Let's
try overseas again. Why don't we go to
Scott from Scotland? What's going on, Scott?
Scott from Scotland, you are muted, you have to
unmuted yourself in order for me to hear you.
My apologies, my friend. Do you hear me?
Well, I do. Fantastic. So a relatively
I don't want to say it's a minor point, but
maybe not high. On the list of priorities is
legal immigration into the US. And I kind of speak
from firsthand experience here. I was I was moved
with work to the US last March when the corporate
situation kicked off. And now we find ourselves
in a kind of precarious and nonmoving position.
And so I know that President Trump is obviously
focused on illegal immigration, but he also did a
pretty good job of decimating illegal immigration,
as well as through the various presidential
orders he put in place. Yes, the last of which
expires at midnight on March 31st, which he
enacted just before New Year's New Year's Day.
So in theory, the presidential orders have
disappeared for the most part, for the kind
of legal immigration bans. But what we're finding
and so this is something our work attorneys are
struggling with, is our embassies and consulates
around the world are still refusing to see people
or offer appointments or even just say when
they're going to start resuming services. So
I just curious from your perspective, where do
you see legal immigration going under this new
administration? And do you think it will improve,
do you think? I don't know, maybe clamp down on
it and kind of readjust the system. Where do you I
don't see a clamp down. What you're describing is
not unique to the United States. I have friends
that are dealing with this in different places.
I have a friend that's in the middle of getting
Portuguese residency through a so-called golden
visa program. And it's just it's taking forever.
I have another friend who's in the middle
of getting Israeli citizenship. All of these
systems are just slowed down. And I think that
it's I as the as we get out of the pandemic,
hopefully over the next six to 12 months,
a lot of these bureaucratic nightmares will
become slightly less nightmarish. But the
question of policy is a different one, I
think, in the immediate things are just
going to go back to the way they were before. The
pandemic policy is going to be dealt with later.
Yeah, that makes a lot of sense, I do know that
Biden and his administration were potentially
looking at kind of changes to the H1 lottery
system in particular and just changing how
how that goes by, I guess would be interesting
to see how that plays out over the coming months,
no doubt about it. And so but so now are you
are you no longer trying to move to the US?
No, we're still in progress. I'm living in a half
packed house and have been since last March. I had
the embassy appointment last March and then they
postponed again and postponed again. We put in an
exemption request for national security exemption.
I work in areas related to national security
and the consulate rejected it without even
reading it. So why we're in a bit of a stage,
a strange day at the moment, but still very
much a pursuit and trying to get things done.
All right. Well, I hope things normalize for you.
Thank you, David. All right, Scott from Scotland,
thank you so much for the call. We are
speaking to folks via discord, as we often do.
You can find the discord at David Pakman dot com
slash discord. That's the way to do it. Let's
go to how about AJ in Oregon or as the former
president said it, Oregon. AJ, what's going on?
Hey, David, can you hear me?
Just barely, A.J., we and we've got you
cranked up and it's just it's just a whisper.
How about now? Is that better?
Barely. Barely. What's going on? Let's
see if we can get your question out.
I was wondering if you had a magic wand to
enact any policy regarding police reform,
what would you change and why?
I have a whole video clip about this where I
lay out about eight to 10 different points,
and it includes training, social work, training
for police officers. We talk about body cameras.
We talk about civilian review boards that actually
work a national bad actors database. There's about
eight to 10 different points. I've outlined it
pretty pretty specifically, and there's probably
even more that that could be added to it. But
definitely check that clip out. It's on YouTube.
OK, but not anything specifically
out of those like there is anything
that you would place above all the others.
I didn't prioritize the list, I mean,
it's a list of about eight to 10 things I did,
I didn't rank them, if that's the question.
OK, I guess more specifically, I was
wondering about the body cameras specifically
and their impact, because I noticed a lot of
times with these issues with police brutality,
we're really dependent on body cam to get
an unbiased sort of recording of the event.
Yeah, my general view is I like the idea of body
cameras, it shouldn't be so easy for them to just
not record at exactly the key moment. And then you
hear about, oh, the footage is missing. The camera
didn't turn on. I know that there are some small
studies that claim complaints for use of force
went up when body cameras were put in place. And
a lot of right wingers will point to that and say,
see, see, we don't need body cameras at the at the
macro level, everything I've read is that use of
force complaints go down when body cameras
are put in place. So I think there's still
details to sort out. But from everything
I've read, I'm in favor of body cameras.
And just the last thing on that thing, would you
in the course of events where a body
cameras turned off or not available,
would you hold the police department accountable
for that missing footage if a body camera
reform was put in place where they required
everyone to record? The course of events.
I don't know how you manage that, because
there's a big difference between the officer
deliberately turns the camera off, which really
it's it's a question whether they should even
have the ability to do that or everything's
recorded and then in the cloud. But somehow
the footage disappears to just genuinely
there's a technical issue. You need a system for
managing all of those different circumstances. I
don't know exactly what that system is right now.
All right, thanks very much. I love the show.
All right, there is A.J., barely audible, but we
were able to make it work. Always a good thing.